So a horse walks into a movie theater, gets his popcorn and a Diet Coke, and sits down in one of the few seats that are left. He realizes right away there's a cow sitting directly in front of him wearing this huge hat, totally inappropriate to wear indoors, one of the big, tall Stetson hats, completely blocking his view. So the horse taps the cow on the shoulder. Excuse me?
有匹马走进电影院，买了爆米花和健怡可乐，坐进为数不多的空位里。他立刻意识到面前坐着一头奶牛，戴着一顶巨大的帽子，在室内戴这种帽子非常不合时宜，是一顶又大又高的牛仔帽，完全挡住了他的视线。于是，马拍了拍牛的肩膀。不好意思？
Cow doesn't budge. No response at all. So again, the horse taps him on the shoulder. Excuse me? The cow is like ice. He's like a statue. So OK, one more time. He taps him on the shoulder. Hey, can you take off your hat? Cow turns around. And he's like, oh, my god, it's a talking horse.
牛纹丝不动。没有任何反应。于是马又拍了拍他的肩膀。不好意思？牛像冰块一样。像座雕像。好吧，再来一次。他拍了拍他的肩膀。嘿，你能把帽子摘了吗？牛转过头。他说，天哪，竟然是只会说话的马。
Not the greatest joke in the world. But what I love about that joke is that for once in the joke, the animals acknowledge that we should not be having animals talking in jokes. That's the actual punchline of the joke. That's the premise.
这并不是世界上最好的笑话。但我喜欢这个笑话的原因是，在这个笑话里，动物们第一次意识到，我们不该在笑话里让动物说话。这才是笑话真正的笑点。这就是前提。
We as human beings are so constantly blurring the line between animals and people in kids' stories, and movies, and the way we talk to our pets. We can't help ourselves. And we do it so much we even have jokes where the animals call us out on it.
作为人类，我们在儿童故事、电影以及和宠物交谈的方式中，总是不断模糊动物与人之间的界限。我们情不自禁。我们做得太过火，甚至会有动物反过来提醒我们的笑话。
And I bring this up because that's our show today. Today in our program, we have two stories of human beings not just trying to blur the line between people and animals but trying to erase that line completely. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us, people.
我提起这个是因为这就是我们今天的节目。今天在节目中，我们有两个故事，讲述的人类不仅试图模糊人与动物之间的界限，而且试图彻底抹去那条线。这里是WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听，各位。
Act One, Monkey in the Middle. So there's some places where animals almost never go, places that are designed by humans for humans. This act ends up in a place like that, but it starts about as far from there as you can get. Dana Chivvis explains.
第一幕，中间的猴子。有些地方动物几乎从不去，那是人类为人类设计的地方。这一幕发生在这样的地方，但开始时却远在天边。达娜·奇维斯解释道。
Our story begins deep in the rainforests of Indonesia on an island called Sulawesi. A few years ago, the photographer David Slater traveled there from his home in England to photograph a troop of monkeys.
我们的故事始于印度尼西亚苏拉威西岛深处的雨林中。几年前，摄影师大卫·斯莱特从英国的家中前往那里，去拍摄一群猴子。
I'd gone a whole day just following them into the thick of the forest, through the tangles and the vines and the muddy undergrowth and the cobwebs and the poisonous snakes.
我花了一整天时间跟着它们进入森林深处，穿过灌木丛、藤蔓、泥泞的灌木丛、蛛网和毒蛇。
Oh, man.
天哪。
You name it, I had to go through it. And it was just so amazing just to be like a monkey. I was a monkey honestly. I had met monkeys before, like I said, all over the world. And I know a little bit about monkey etiquette and showing your teeth-- not to show your teeth, not to stare them in the face. Yeah, this is one of the secrets, actually, of being able to get good photography is making the animal relaxed.
只要你能想到的，我都经历过。能像猴子一样生活真的很神奇。我真的成了一只猴子。正如我所说，我以前在世界各地见过猴子。我知道一点猴子的礼仪，比如露齿——不能露齿，不能盯着它们的脸看。是的，事实上，能拍出好照片的秘诀之一就是让动物放松。
There was one shot David really wanted to get-- a full face portrait with a wide angle lens. But every time he got close to taking the shot, the monkeys would look away. So after two days of these near misses, he changed strategies.
大卫真的很想拍一张照片——用广角镜头拍摄的全脸肖像。但每次他靠近拍照时，猴子都会转过头去。在经历了两次几乎成功却又错失机会后，他改变了策略。
He put his camera on a tripod and threw down some cookies to try to entice the monkeys over. He was hoping they'd get curious about the camera and start pushing the button themselves. They were curious. They were not pushing the button. So David attached a cable with a button on the end of it to the camera. The monkeys liked that. They started playing with it, putting it in their mouths, fighting over it.
他把相机放在三脚架上，扔了一些饼干试图引诱猴子过来。他希望它们对相机产生好奇，并开始自己按下按钮。它们确实好奇，但并没有按下按钮。于是大卫在相机上连了一根带按钮的线。猴子喜欢那个。它们开始玩弄它，放进嘴里，抢来抢去。
And of course when it got pressed, they automatically looked into the lens. And the fact that it's going ch, ch, ch, ch, ch, it's monkey language.
当然，当按钮被按下时，它们会自动看向镜头。而且那咔哒、咔哒的声音，那是猴子的语言。
They fired off a few shots. David reviewed them. They weren't bad, a little out of focus. So he adjusted the settings and put the camera back. The monkeys were into the whole project by now.
它们拍了几张照片。大卫检查了一下。还不错，就是稍微有点对焦模糊。所以他调整了设置，又把相机放回去。此时猴子们已经完全投入到整个项目中了。
In fact, they were getting a little too excited. They almost knocked the tripod over. So David laid down on his stomach and stretched his arm out to steady the tripod with two fingers. A few other monkeys noticed their strange new friend lying full out on the floor and hopped onto his back.
事实上，它们变得有点太兴奋了。它们差点把三脚架撞倒。所以大卫趴在地上，伸出手臂用两根手指稳住三脚架。其他几只猴子注意到这个奇怪的新朋友趴在地上一动不动，就跳到了他的背上。
So I had monkeys on my back whilst I'm trying to keep my camera from being knocked, while some monkeys, or two or three monkeys, are trying to play with the button. And all of a sudden, I heard the camera going off. And I didn't dare. I knew that if I looked up at them, they would probably look away. So I let them click it, click it, click it. And I sort of very carefully looked up to see them pulling these amazing contorted faces, like howling mouths, and the smiling mouth, and more besides.
所以我背上驮着猴子，同时努力不让相机被撞倒，而另外两三只猴子在试图玩按钮。突然，我听到相机开始咔咔作响。我不敢乱动。我知道如果我抬头看它们，它们很可能会转过头去。所以我让它们点按，一次又一次。我非常小心地抬头看了一眼，看到它们做了各种神奇夸张的表情，像嚎叫的嘴，微笑的嘴，还有其他的。
The monkeys were taking selfies-- amazing, beautiful, weird selfies.
猴子们在自拍——令人惊叹、美丽又古怪的自拍。
I just wanted it to go on forever really.
我真希望这一切能永远持续下去。
When David finally stood up and checked their work, he saw that the shots weren't just regular, old, everyday selfies. They weren't that guy at the gym taking pictures of his muscles in the mirror. These were next level, transcendentally good. They somehow escape the bounds of selfie and enter the realm of art.
当大卫终于站起来检查它们的作品时，他发现这些照片不仅仅是普通的、随意的日常自拍。它们不是那种在健身房对着镜子拍自己肌肉的家伙。这些是更高层次的、超越性的优秀作品。它们以某种方式逃脱了自拍的局限，进入了艺术的领域。
There was one shot in particular that caught David's eye. The monkey's face is very close to the camera looking straight into the lens. It's hair perfectly coiffed. Eyes friendly, big and round and amber. All of which are nice details, and details are important. But the focus of this selfie, the main event, is the monkey's self-satisfied grin-- teeth that are too big for its mouth with gaps between them, a real grin, like he knows he's smiling for a picture.
有一张照片特别吸引大卫的注意。猴子的脸非常靠近相机，直视镜头。毛发梳理得完美无瑕。眼睛友好、又大又圆、呈琥珀色。所有这些都是很好的细节，细节很重要。但这张自拍的焦点，重头戏，是猴子那种自鸣得意的咧嘴笑——牙齿大得塞不下嘴，牙齿之间还有缝隙，真正的咧嘴笑，就像他知道自己在对着镜头微笑一样。
I just saw it on the front cover of National Geographic or something like that. And I just thought, I need to get this to my agents.
我当时就在想，这张照片可以做《国家地理》之类的杂志封面。我当时就想，我得把它发给我的代理人。
David and his agents put out a press release about the selfies. They thought they could grab people's attention with the photos and then use the opportunity to send a message about conservation. And also they wanted to sell the pictures, of course.
大卫和他的代理人发布了关于这些自拍的新闻稿。他们认为可以通过这些照片抓住人们的眼球，然后利用这个机会传达关于保护动物的信息。当然，他们也想卖掉这些照片。
These monkeys, crested black macaques, are considered to be critically endangered, which is just one step before extinct in the wild. They've lost 80% of their population in the last 40 years because of humans, which is why David went to Indonesia in the first place. He wanted to take photographs that would inspire us humans into caring more about these little monkeys, to stop killing them. The selfies didn't end up on the cover of National Geographic, but the British tabloids were interested. The Daily Mail was the first newspaper to publish the story about the selfies. This was in 2011.
这些黑冠猕猴被认为是极度濒危物种，也就是仅次于野外灭绝的程度。由于人类的原因，它们在过去40年里失去了80%的种群数量，这就是大卫最初去印度尼西亚的原因。他想拍一些照片，激发我们人类对这些小猴子的关心，停止猎杀它们。这些自拍最终没能登上《国家地理》的封面，但英国的小报却很感兴趣。《每日邮报》是第一家刊登关于这些自拍故事的报纸。那是在2011年。
Within an hour, it was all over your country, Australia, Germany. I was getting emails everywhere. My inbox went crazy. People wanting to know the story, wanted to use the image. Literally, my phone was hot with calls.
一小时内，整个国家、澳大利亚、德国到处都是。我到处收到邮件。我的收件箱快炸了。人们想知道故事，想使用这张照片。真的，我的电话因为不断的来电而发烫。
Over the next few months, the monkey selfies sold pretty well. David was licensing them to publications and selling prints. And then one day, he goes online to research the monkeys.
在接下来的几个月里，这些猴子自拍卖得相当不错。大卫把它们授权给出版物并出售照片。然后有一天，他上网搜索这些猴子。
I started to just search crested black macaque one day in the Google. And there was Wikipedia, top of the list as always. I clicked on that, and there's my image. And I thought, where have they got this from? Have they been to Caters News Agency and paid a license fee for it?
有一天我在谷歌上搜索黑冠猕猴。维基百科排在列表第一位，一如既往。我点击进去，看到了我的照片。我心想，他们是从哪弄来的？他们去过凯特斯新闻社并支付了版权费吗？
They had not.
他们没有。
So I sent them a letter. Sent them a letter saying, I think you're using this without a license fee. Could you show me one, or would you pay? They wrote back, saying, this image we believe is public domain.
所以我给他们写了一封信。信中说，我认为你们在没有支付版权费的情况下使用了这张照片。你们能出示授权书，或者支付费用吗？他们回信说，我们认为这张照片属于公有领域。
In other words, anyone could use it without David's permission, for free. To David, that was just stealing. He makes a living from selling his pictures. So it was really helpful to have one that was such a hit. But now, anyone could download it from Wikipedia and hang it on their wall or print it in their publication. Wikipedia's opinion is that information on the internet should be free. And David soon learned that they had decided the selfie was in the public domain--
换句话说，任何人都可以免费使用它，无需大卫的许可。对大卫来说，这就是偷窃。他靠卖照片为生。所以能拍到这样一张轰动一时的照片真的很有帮助。但现在，任何人都可以从维基百科下载它，挂在墙上或印在出版物中。维基百科的观点是互联网上的信息应该免费。大卫很快了解到，他们已经认定这张自拍属于公有领域——
Because the monkey pressed the button.
因为是猴子按下的按钮。
So the monkey was technically the creator of the photo. But in Wikipedia's assessment, monkeys can't own copyrights. Hence, the photo was free and fair for all to use. It belonged to the internet. David was baffled. He thought--
所以从技术上讲，猴子是这张照片的创作者。但在维基百科的评估中，猴子不能拥有版权。因此，这张照片是免费的，人人可用。它属于互联网。大卫感到困惑。他想——
Well, surely I've got the copyright. I set it all up. I've got the intent. I had the creativity. All the monkey did is press the button.
嗯，版权肯定在我手里。是我安排好了一切。我有意图。我有创造力。猴子所做的只是按下了按钮。
Wikipedia includes a note below the photo, which reads, quote, "This file is in the public domain because as the work of a non-human animal it has no human author in whom copyright is vested." This decision of Wikipedia's, to declare the photo public domain, that was the opening volley in the monkey selfie battle to come. It was the moment when mother nature was shoved aside, and human nature, with its overstuffed baggage of laws and opinions and domination, took a seat.
维基百科在照片下方加了一段注释，上面写着：“此文件属于公有领域，因为它是非人类动物的作品，没有人类作者拥有版权。”维基百科宣布这张照片为公有领域的决定，是即将到来的“猴子自拍大战”的第一波攻势。那一刻，大自然被推到了一边，而人性——带着它那沉重的法律和观点包袱——占据了主导地位。
David went on the offensive, assembled a team of lawyers, studied up on copyright law. He even looked into finding venture capitalists to fund a lawsuit against Wikipedia. Wikimedia-- that's the foundation that owns Wikipedia-- they just gave him the finger. This was at their big conference in London. It's called Wikimania. One of the founders, Jimmy Wales, was there.
大卫开始反击，组建了律师团队，研究了版权法。他甚至考虑寻找风险投资人来资助起诉维基百科。维基媒体——也就是拥有维基百科的基金会——直接对他竖起了中指。这发生在他们在伦敦举行的大型会议上。会议叫“维基媒体国际大会”。创始人之一吉米·威尔士也在那里。
I soon got to know, from the good Wikipedians out there, that Jimmy Wales and many of the delegates were mocking me by printing out my image on great big boards that were placed all over the conference facility. And Jimmy Wales and various other people were encouraging the delegates to take selfies with my selfie.
我很快从那些优秀的维基人那里得知，吉米·威尔士和许多代表在嘲笑我，他们把我的照片打印在巨大的展板上，放在会议场所的各处。吉米·威尔士和其他人还鼓励代表们拿着我的自拍进行自拍。
That's just mean.
那太刻薄了。
There's quite a few of these images around the place on the internet, but the one with Jimmy Wales is particularly odious.
互联网上有很多这样的照片，但吉米·威尔士的那张特别令人反感。
Wait. I want to look that up really fast here. Hang on.
等等。我想快点查一下这个。等等。
Yeah.
是的。
Jimmy Wales monkey selfie.
吉米·威尔士猴子自拍。
Jimmy Wales Wikimania.
吉米·威尔士 维基媒体国际大会。
Here we go. Oh, yeah. Look at that. If you type Jimmy Wales monkey selfie into the Google, you'll find a photo of an adult male human holding his phone up in one hand and the monkey selfie in the other right next to his face. And he's got his lips puckered up like a duck.
就是这个。哦，是的。你看。如果你在谷歌输入“吉米·威尔士 猴子自拍”，你会发现一张照片，一个成年男性手里拿着手机，另一只手里拿着那张猴子自拍，就在他脸旁边。他噘着嘴，像只鸭子。
He looks ridiculous. Now, is he-- is that face he's making-- is that--
他看起来很滑稽。现在，他是——他做的那个表情——那是——
Well, it's like a duck face. I don't know where that comes from.
嗯，那是鸭子脸。我不知道那是从哪来的。
I don't either.
我也不知道。
But a lot of people seem to do this duck lips.
但很多人似乎都喜欢这种鸭子嘴。
How did you feel when you saw that Jimmy Wales selfie with your monkey selfie?
当你看到吉米·威尔士那张和你猴子自拍的合影时，你感觉如何？
So angry.
太生气了。
David was fighting Goliath. And then one day, the battle took on epic new proportions. It was like King Kong walked onto the scene, and now David had to battle him too. The dispute with Wikimedia had generated some press in the UK. And one day, David's wife was online.
大卫在与巨人作战。然后有一天，这场战斗展现出了新的史诗级规模。就像金刚闯入了现场，现在大卫还得跟他战斗。与维基媒体的纠纷在英国引起了一些媒体报道。有一天，大卫的妻子正在上网。
There it was. Photographer being sued by a monkey.
就在那里。摄影师被一只猴子起诉。
You found out the monkey was suing you because your wife found it online.
你发现那只猴子在起诉你，是因为你妻子在网上看到的？
Yeah. Just as I found out Wikipedia was stealing it because I stumbled across it, I also stumbled across the fact that I was being sued by a monkey.
是的。就像我因为偶然发现而得知维基百科在偷我的照片一样，我也偶然发现我正被一只猴子起诉。
The monkey in the selfie photos was suing him for copyright infringement with the help of PETA, People for the Ethical Treatment of Animals. David called his lawyers and said--
自拍照片中的那只猴子，在善待动物组织（PETA）的帮助下，正以侵犯版权为由起诉他。大卫给他的律师打电话说——
Look. Have you seen what's happening now? What can we do? And they said, Dave, this is clearly an April Fools'. Somebody is having you on. They said, just sit back. Let's see what happens. But do not respond to it. And you can't-- you've got nothing to worry about until you get served papers. Let's see what happens.
听着。你看到现在发生什么了吗？我们该怎么办？他们说，戴夫，这显然是个愚人节玩笑。有人在捉弄你。他们说，先坐着别动。看看会发生什么。但在收到传票之前，你不需要——你没什么可担心的。看看会发生什么。
Right.
好吧。
And sure enough, one afternoon I was at home. And there's a knock at the door. And a man in a black suit was standing in my porch way. I opened the door. He thrust a large A4-sized white envelope in my hand. And he says, I've been instructed to pass these to you. So I said, what are they?
结果，一天下午我在家里。门铃响了。一个穿黑西装的男人站在我门廊上。我打开门。他塞给我一个大A4纸大小的白色信封。他说，我受命把这些交给你。我说，这是什么？
And I opened it in front of him. And I took it out. And I said to him, do you know what this is? And he said, not really. I said, I'm being sued by a monkey. And I showed him. And he started laughing. And we had a little chat. Because he was just a local from a local firm down the road from me. And he went on his merry way.
我在他面前打开它。我拿出来。我对他说，你知道这是什么吗？他说，不太清楚。我说，我被一只猴子起诉了。我给他看了。他开始大笑。我们聊了几句。因为他只是我家附近一家当地律师事务所的人。然后他就高高兴兴地走了。
I've read the complaint. It's kind of weird. You flip through pages and pages of legalese about copyright law. And then at the end when you get to the exhibits, it's just a bunch of monkey selfies, grinning, serious, howling monkey selfies-- like a legal document put together by Curious George. The monkey, whose name is Naruto, was suing David through his next friends, People for the Ethical Treatment of Animals.
我读了那份诉状。有点奇怪。你翻过一页又一页关于版权法的法律术语。然后在最后，当你看到证据时，只是一堆猴子自拍，咧嘴笑的、严肃的、嚎叫的猴子自拍——就像好奇的乔治整理出来的法律文件。那只名叫纳鲁托的猴子，正通过他的“近亲朋友”——善待动物组织起诉大卫。
The case is officially called Naruto, a Crested Macaque, by and through his Next Friends, People for the Ethical Treatment of Animals, Inc., v David John Slater, an Individual. In legal parlance, next friend is a status like guardian. When someone can't represent themselves in court, the next friend can step in for them.
该案的正式名称是“纳鲁托，一只黑冠猕猴，通过其近亲朋友善待动物组织，诉大卫·约翰·斯莱特个人”。在法律术语中，“近亲朋友”是一种类似于监护人的身份。当某人在法庭上无法为自己辩护时，近亲朋友可以介入。
That's just the same as if it was a baby or a disabled adult who couldn't speak or represent himself.
那和婴儿或无法说话或表达自己的残疾成年人是一样的。
I see.
我明白了。
That's not unusual in human law.
在人类法律中这并不罕见。
PETA has a reputation for pulling stunts to attract attention to the plight of animals. Once, they dumped horse manure on the sidewalk outside Gordon Ramsay's restaurant in London after a guest on his cooking show made a dish with horse meat. They made a comic book called Your Mommy Kills Animals and then handed it out to moms who were wearing fur coats at performances of the Nutcracker. They campaigned to change the word fish to sea kittens so that people would associate seafood with their adorable kitty cats and stop eating them-- the fish, I mean. But Jeff Kerr-- he's the general counsel to PETA-- he says this monkey selfie case is not one of those stunts.
善待动物组织以制造噱头来吸引人们对动物处境的关注而闻名。有一次，他们在伦敦戈登·拉姆齐的餐厅外的人行道上倒了马粪，因为他烹饪节目的一位嘉宾做了一道马肉菜肴。他们制作了一本名为《你的妈妈杀害动物》的漫画书，然后在《胡桃夹子》的演出场地分发给穿着皮草大衣的妈妈们。他们发起运动，将“鱼”这个词改为“海猫”，这样人们就会把海鲜和可爱的猫咪联系起来，从而停止吃它们——我是指鱼。但杰夫·克尔——他是PETA的总法律顾问——他说这个猴子自拍案并不是那种噱头。
We first saw the monkey selfie in approximately 2014 when the dispute between Mr. Slater and Wikimedia became international news. Our view was immediately that Naruto, who created the photograph, should own the copyright to it.
我们第一次看到猴子自拍是在2014年左右，当时斯莱特先生和维基媒体之间的纠纷成为国际新闻。我们的观点立即是，创作了这张照片的纳鲁托应该拥有它的版权。
Jeff saw the dispute as this photographer wants to sue Wikimedia, and Wikimedia is claiming the photo is in the public domain. But who's standing up for the monkey?
杰夫眼中的这场纠纷是：这位摄影师想起诉维基媒体，而维基媒体声称照片属于公有领域。但是谁在为猴子挺身而出呢？
That's what the law is. And our argument, very simply, is that that should apply equally to him, even though he simply happens not to have been born human.
这就是法律的意义所在。我们的论点非常简单，那就是法律应该同等地适用于他，即使他恰好不是人类。
But certainly the monkey didn't think like, now this is great. I've got a camera in my hands. I'm going to snap a couple frames and update my Bumble profile with whatever I get. The monkey's not thinking of it as, I'm taking a photograph here.
但当然，猴子并没有想，“现在这太棒了。我手里有台相机。我要拍两张照片，然后用我拍的照片更新我的Bumble个人资料。”猴子并没有想，“我在这里拍照。”
But that's not required under the copyright law. All that's required is that-- the copyright law simply provides that the author, the creator of the image, is entitled to own it. It doesn't say that the author has to know that he or she is making a photograph. If somebody gives you their camera and asks you to take a photograph, and you arrange them and you take the photograph, under those circumstances, you technically would own the copyright.
但版权法并不要求这一点。版权法只是规定，作者，即图像的创作者，有权拥有它。它并没有说作者必须知道他或她正在制作一张照片。如果有人把相机给你并请你拍照，你安排好他们并拍下了照片，在这种情况下，从技术上讲，你拥有版权。
There are like 20 French tourists that I need to sue.
我有大约20个法国游客需要起诉。
PETA is an American organization. And the case was to be heard in federal court in San Francisco. David talked to his lawyers in England. And they told him he needed to hire an American attorney and fight this.
善待动物组织是一个美国组织。案件将在旧金山的联邦法院审理。大卫和他在英国的律师谈过。他们告诉他需要雇佣一名美国律师来打这场官司。
I was advised by talking to these attorneys that I really did need to follow this through, because there would be a chance, an outside chance albeit, of it just going the monkey's way if I didn't challenge it.
通过与这些律师交谈，我得到的建议是，我确实需要把这件事坚持下去，因为如果不反驳，如果我不挑战，哪怕机会微乎其微，它也可能会按猴子的方式发展。
The monkey would win?
猴子会赢？
Yeah. Well, it was in the court in California. And everybody has the opinion that anything can happen there. I don't know how true that is. But I was being told I can't take that risk. But of course--
是的。嗯，是在加州的法庭。每个人都认为那里什么事都可能发生。我不知道那有多真实。但我被告知我不能冒那个险。当然——
Have you been to California?
你去过加州吗？
Well, no.
嗯，没有。
It's kind of true.
那是真的。
David hired Andrew Dhuey to represent him.
大卫雇佣了安德鲁·杜伊作为他的代理人。
Do you remember when you first heard about the case? Was it when-- did David call you? Is that how you first heard about it?
你还记得第一次听到这个案子的时候吗？是——是大卫给你打的电话？你是这样听说的吗？
No, I read about it. And I don't remember where I read about it. But I got pretty excited when I saw that it was filed in San Francisco federal court because I'm right across the bay in Berkeley. So I thought, wow, I would be perfect for this case.
不，我是读到的。我不记得是在哪读到的了。但当我看到它在旧金山联邦法院提起诉讼时，我感到很兴奋，因为我就在湾对面的伯克利。所以我心想，哇，我太适合这个案子了。
Andrew is an intellectual property lawyer. Works for himself. And when he read about the case, he reached out to David to ask if he could take it.
安德鲁是一名知识产权律师。自由职业者。当他读到这个案子时，他联系了大卫，询问他是否可以承接。
Why did you think you were perfect for the case?
为什么你认为你适合这个案子？
Well, I think the case kind of lent itself to making monkey puns and things like that. And I just thought that would be-- I kind of like to do that. I like to joke around. I don't know if you've seen my LinkedIn profile. I'm in a Chippendales costume.
嗯，我认为这个案子本身就适合编猴子的双关语之类的东西。我就是觉得那会——我有点喜欢那样。我喜欢开玩笑。我不知道你有没有看过我的领英资料。我穿着奇彭代尔舞者的服装。
For his LinkedIn picture, Andrew chose a shot of himself wearing eyeglasses, a bow tie, and nothing else.
在领英头像上，安德鲁选择了一张他戴着眼镜、系着领结、什么也没穿的照片。
All these years-- I've been practicing for like 25 years, and I've never been able to joke around in anything I filed in court. So I was like, hey, this would actually be a case where I could do that.
这些年来——我已经执业大约25年了，我从来没能在法庭文件中开过玩笑。所以我当时心想，嘿，这会是一个我可以那样做的案子。
That said, he's a real intellectual property lawyer. He's defended the toy company Wham-O, won an important case against Panasonic. And for Andrew, the case was a one banana problem. He answered Naruto's complaint with a motion to dismiss the case. Monkeys, he said, do not have standing to sue in federal court.
话虽如此，他是一位真正的知识产权律师。他曾为玩具公司Wham-O辩护，赢得了一场针对松下的重要官司。对安德鲁来说，这案子是“一个香蕉问题”。他用撤诉动议回应了纳鲁托的诉状。他说，猴子没有在联邦法院起诉的资格。
His argument is based on a precedent set in 2004 in a case called Cetacean Community v George W. Bush, in which all the world's whales, porpoises, and dolphins sued the president. All the world's whales, porpoises, and dolphins argued that the military's use of underwater sonar was hurting them, changing their natural behaviors, like eating and mating. Basically, sonar is just an incredibly loud sound wave.
他的论点基于2004年一个名为“鲸豚社区诉乔治·W·布什”的案件中所确立的先例，当时世界上所有的鲸鱼、海豚和鼠海豚起诉了总统。世界上所有的鲸鱼、海豚和鼠海豚辩称，军方在水下使用声纳伤害了它们，改变了它们的自然行为，如进食和交配。基本上，声纳只是极其响亮的声波。
So cetaceans, that's a scientific word for a category of marine mammal-- cetaceans flee when they hear sonar, sometimes even beating themselves to get away. In that case, the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals decided that unless Congress explicitly states otherwise, animals do not have standing to sue in federal court. So that's the case Andrew pointed to in his defense.
所以鲸豚类——这是海洋哺乳动物类别的科学词汇——听到声纳就会逃跑，有时甚至因为逃跑而自残。在那起案件中，第九巡回上诉法院裁定，除非国会明确规定，否则动物在联邦法院没有起诉资格。这就是安德鲁在辩护中指出的案例。
But PETA hired an outside attorney to represent the monkey Naruto in court, a guy named David Schwarz. This guy, Schwarz, he comes from a fancy law firm in Los Angeles known for intellectual property law. Most of his case was an intellectual property argument that Naruto was the legal owner of the copyright because he was the one who made the photo.
但是善待动物组织雇佣了一名外部律师在法庭上为猴子纳鲁托辩护，一个叫大卫·施瓦茨的人。这个施瓦茨来自洛杉矶一家以知识产权法闻名的豪华律师事务所。他大部分的陈述是一个知识产权论点，即纳鲁托是版权的合法所有者，因为他是拍摄照片的人。
But PETA also saw this case as an opportunity to nudge the law and set a precedent. They disagreed with the ruling in the cetacean case. They believe animals should have recourse in court.
但善待动物组织也认为这是一个推动法律和设立先例的机会。他们不同意鲸豚案的裁决。他们认为动物应该有权在法庭上进行诉求。
Calling civil matter 15-4324, Naruto v David John Slater, et al. Counsel, please come forward and state your appearance.
传唤民事案件15-4324，纳鲁托诉大卫·约翰·斯莱特等。律师，请上前说明你们的代理关系。
This is a recording from the hearing in the federal district court in San Francisco. The judge asked Schwarz if he has an example of an animal ever being granted a copyright.
这是旧金山联邦地方法院听证会的录音。法官问施瓦茨是否有动物被授予版权的例子。
In the vast history of common law prior to the Copyright Act, was there-- do you have an example of where an animal was granted a copyright?
在版权法之前的漫长普通法历史中，是否有——你有没有动物被授予版权的例子？
I do not have an example where an animal was granted a copyright. We could make the counterargument as to how other humans were denied protection under that law due to the color of their skin. One could see the contradiction in a statutory interpretation where we see that problem in the antebellum days. But when you look at the cornerstones of--
我没有动物被授予版权的例子。我们可以反驳，在那个法律下，其他人是如何因皮肤颜色而剥夺保护的。在内战前的日子里，当我们看到那个问题时，可以在法定解释中看到矛盾。但当你看看……的基石时。
That's quite a stretch, Mr. Schwarz.
这太牵强了，施瓦茨先生。
Just to pause on this for a moment. Yes, Schwarz is comparing a monkey's lack of copyright to chattel slavery, which is offensive and seems weirdly blind to the racist history of comparing black people and monkeys. Even Schwarz seems uncomfortable with it. He's saying that denying a monkey the right to own property because of its species is the same as denying humans the right to own property because of the color of their skin.
暂停一下。是的，施瓦茨正在把猴子缺乏版权与蓄奴制进行比较，这令人反感，而且对黑人和猴子进行比较的种族主义历史似乎表现得非常盲目。连施瓦茨本人似乎也感到不舒服。他是在说，基于物种剥夺猴子的财产所有权，就像基于肤色剥夺人类的财产所有权一样。
That's quite a stretch, Mr. Schwarz.
这太牵强了，施瓦茨先生。
Pardon me?
你说什么？
That's quite a stretch. But go ahead.
太牵强了。但请继续。
And I certainly wouldn't make it the centerpiece of any argument here today. But it is fair to say that before the adoption of the 14th Amendment, the concepts of property ownership in the area of patents foreclosed the ability of a slave to claim ownership to a patent.
但我肯定不会把它作为今天任何论点的核心。但公平地说，在第14修正案通过之前，专利领域的财产所有权概念剥夺了奴隶申请专利所有权的能力。
What's going on here is that PETA sees the monkey selfie case in the context of a larger end game. If they can get a court to agree that denying a monkey the right to own property is the same as denying a human the right to own property, that opens the door for the legal system to completely reconsider the legal status of animals. An animal would be declared an owner of property instead of just being property.
这里发生的事情是，PETA在更大博弈的背景下看待猴子自拍案。如果他们能让法庭同意剥夺猴子的财产所有权与剥夺人类的财产所有权是一样的，那就为法律体系彻底重新考虑动物的法律地位打开了大门。动物将被宣布为财产所有者，而不是仅仅被视为财产。
This isn't the first time PETA has tried an argument like this in the courts. In 2011, they sued SeaWorld on behalf of five orcas at SeaWorld Orlando and SeaWorld San Diego. Orcas are huge, 20 to 30 feet long. And they weigh about six tons. They typically travel around 75 miles in a day.
这不是善待动物组织第一次在法庭上尝试这种论点。2011年，他们代表奥兰多和圣地亚哥海洋世界的五只虎鲸起诉了海洋世界。虎鲸非常巨大，长20到30英尺，重约6吨。它们一天通常游行约75英里。
PETA said that keeping these orcas at SeaWorld in small concrete tanks against their will to perform for human entertainment, that was slavery. PETA lost that case. But SeaWorld has agreed to end its captive orca program after the last of their 27 orcas dies.
PETA表示，将这些虎鲸违背意愿关在海洋世界的小型混凝土水箱中为人类娱乐表演，这就是奴隶制。PETA输掉了那场官司。但海洋世界已同意在现存的27只虎鲸死后，结束其圈养虎鲸计划。
To understand why PETA is pursuing cases like these, you have to consider two very different pictures about how the world works. In one of them, humans are at the top of the food chain-- either because God wanted it that way, or because we figured out how to use our opposable thumbs so well that we could hunt and gather, and till the soil, and build cities, and create copyright laws. We make the rules for everything else in this world.
要理解为什么PETA要进行这样的诉讼，你必须考虑关于世界如何运作的两幅截然不同的图景。在其中一种中，人类处于食物链的顶端——要么是因为上帝想要这样，要么是因为我们太擅长使用我们的对生拇指，以至于我们可以狩猎采集、耕种土地、建造城市并制定版权法。我们为这个世界上的一切制定规则。
And the other picture-- and this is the one PETA has hanging on their wall-- humans are not at the top. Humans are just another mammal walking around on earth. And if we're going to give ourselves certain rights as humans, we should extend those rights to our fellow animals.
而另一幅图景——也就是PETA挂在墙上的那一幅——人类不是处于顶端。人类只是地球上行走的另一种哺乳动物。如果我们作为人类赋予自己某些权利，我们应该将这些权利延伸到我们的动物同胞身上。
You guys are saying humans are not superior to other animals.
你们是在说人类并不优于其他动物。
We're not. We are just another member of the animal kingdom. And it doesn't-- it's just prejudice and hubris that prevents us many times from seeing that.
我们并不优越。我们只是动物界的另一个成员。通常是偏见和狂妄阻止我们看到这一点。
This is Jeff Kerr again, the general counsel to PETA.
这是杰夫·克尔，PETA的总法律顾问。
That property status is something that we think is just an abomination. Like Naruto, these animals are feeling, sentient beings. They should be entitled to fundamental legal rights beyond simply food, water, veterinary care, and shelter.
这种财产地位是我们认为的一种令人厌恶的事情。像纳鲁托一样，这些动物是有感知能力的生物。他们应该拥有除了食物、水、兽医护理和住所之外的根本法律权利。
This idea that animals should have recognized, fundamental legal rights is not unprecedented. Three years ago in Argentina, a judge granted a habeas corpus petition filed on behalf of an orangutan at a zoo in Buenos Aires. She was being held in a tiny, crappy cage. The judge decided the orangutan had basic rights as a non-human person, including the right to freedom. And in New York state, an attorney is fighting to get the courts to recognize that two captive chimps, Tommy and Kiko, are non-human persons deserving of legal rights, just like corporations get.
这种认为动物应该拥有公认的、根本法律权利的想法并非没有先例。三年前，在阿根廷，一位法官批准了一项代表布宜诺斯艾利斯动物园一只红毛猩猩提交的人身保护令。她被关在一个破烂的小笼子里。法官裁定，这只红毛猩猩作为“非人类人员”拥有基本权利，包括自由权。在纽约州，一位律师正在努力争取法院承认两只被圈养的黑猩猩，汤米和基科，是应该享有法律权利的“非人类人员”，就像公司享有权利一样。
The thing is-- David Slater, the photographer who's getting sued by the monkey, he agrees with PETA on this point. In fact, he used to defend PETA to his friends when they grumbled about the stunts. David even worked with them once on a campaign to protect wild hogs near his home in England.
问题是——大卫·斯莱特，那个被猴子起诉的摄影师，他在这一点上同意PETA。事实上，当他的朋友抱怨这些噱头时，他过去常常为PETA辩护。大卫甚至曾与他们合作开展过一项保护他英国住所附近野猪的运动。
That's one of the greatest shames on them is that they've attacked somebody who is trying to achieve the same goal as they are. Saving animals from suffering is a very noble cause. But I think sometimes they get carried away with their power.
他们最大的羞耻之一就是攻击了一个与他们有着相同目标的人。拯救动物免受痛苦是一项非常崇高的事业。但我认为有时他们被权力冲昏了头脑。
Did the fact that this group that's sort of on your side was the one kind of attacking you or opposing you, did that make you stop ever and think, well, now, wait a minute? Do they have a point?
这个站在你这边的组织攻击或反对你，这有没有让你停下来思考一下，嗯，等等。他们有道理吗？
No. I've had to think very carefully about what my philosophy is. Because the book, my Wildlife Personalities book, that's part of the court case, I argue for animals having more fundamental rights, like dignity, and access to their ancestral forests, and access to food. So I am an animal rights advocate.
没有。我不得不非常仔细地思考我的哲学是什么。因为那本书，我的《野生动物人格》书，那是法庭案件的一部分，我主张动物拥有更多的根本权利，如尊严，进入它们的祖先森林，以及获得食物。所以我是一名动物权利倡导者。
Naruto and PETA lost that first round in court. Andrew Dhuey called David to tell him the news.
纳鲁托和PETA输掉了法庭的第一回合。安德鲁·杜伊打电话告诉大卫这个消息。
We just took it very casually. We just said, yeah, of course. Of course that's going to get thrown out. Andrew Dhuey said this all along to me. There's no way that this is going to go anywhere.
我们只是很随意地对待它。我们只是说，是的，当然。当然这会被驳回。安德鲁·杜伊一直对我这么说。这事不可能有任何进展。
And then the monkey appealed.
然后猴子上诉了。
Good morning, Your Honors. And may it please the court, David Schwarz on behalf of the appellant.
早上好，法官阁下。请允许法庭允许，我是代表上诉人的大卫·施瓦茨。
The case went before three judges on the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals. That's the court that ruled against Trump's travel ban twice this year. These judges are not messing around. Schwarz made it 30 seconds into his oral argument before one of the judges interrupted him.
案件提交到了第九巡回上诉法院的三位法官面前。那是今年两次裁定反对特朗普旅行禁令的法院。这些法官可不是好惹的。施瓦茨在口头辩论开始30秒后就被其中一名法官打断了。
Mr. Schwarz, before we get there, there's a preliminary question which I'd like you to address.
施瓦茨先生，在那之前，有一个初步问题我想请你解决。
At this stage, the attorneys and the judges are going to debate case law. And the judges have a lot of questions for Schwarz-- the first being, how are you qualified to be Naruto's next friend? You don't know the monkey. And then a few minutes later, Judge Randy Smith interrupts Schwarz to grill him about injury. That's the legal term for harm or damage.
在这个阶段，律师和法官们开始辩论判例法。法官们对施瓦茨有很多问题——首先是，你有什么资格成为纳鲁托的近亲朋友？你并不认识这只猴子。几分钟后，兰迪·史密斯法官打断施瓦茨，盘问他关于“伤害”的问题。这是伤害或损失的法律术语。
Well, what's your injury? There's no way to acquire or hold some money which the copyright would give. There's no losses to reputation. There's no even allegation that the copyright could have benefited somehow Naruto. What financial benefits apply to him? There's nothing.
那么，你的伤害是什么？版权带来的钱，根本没法获得或持有。没有声誉损失。甚至没有指控说版权可能以某种方式使纳鲁托受益。他能获得什么经济利益？什么都没有。
But, Your Honor, the redressability issue doesn't necessarily turn on the compensation. It could be--
但是，法官阁下，可补救性问题并不一定取决于补偿。可能是——
Well, I want to know what then is the injury. There's no case that says copyright infringement itself is injury. So what injury do we have?
嗯，我想知道那伤害究竟是什么。没有案件说侵犯版权本身就是伤害。那么我们有什么伤害？
Whatever the legal merits of this case are, there's just something really enjoyable about hearing lawyers throw around terms like redressability and compensation and injury when they're talking about a monkey.
无论此案的法律依据是什么，听到律师在谈论猴子时使用“可补救性”、“补偿”和“伤害”等术语，确实有些非常有趣的地方。
I mean, if you give me a case that says copyright infringement itself is injury, I'll believe you. But I don't think you've given me one. What's your injury?
我是说，如果你能给我一个案例说侵犯版权本身就是伤害，我会相信你。但我不认为你给我提供过。你的伤害是什么？
The judges and Schwarz volley over case law and legal precedent and the definition of author for 20 minutes before handing the floor to David's lawyer, Andrew Dhuey. And after two years of research and legal filings and oral arguments, Dhuey finally gets his wish to make a monkey joke in court.
法官和施瓦茨就判例法、法律先例和“作者”的定义进行了20分钟的激辩，然后将发言权交给了大卫的律师安德鲁·杜伊。经过两年的研究、法律文件提交和口头辩论，杜伊终于得偿所愿，在法庭上讲了一个猴子笑话。
Monkey see, monkey sue will not do in federal court.
“猴子见，猴子诉”在联邦法院行不通。
After that, his oral arguments can pretty much be summed up as, you should throw this case out. And can you please make PETA pay my legal fees? Once Dhuey is done, Angela Dunning gets up. She's the codefendant's attorney. PETA also sued the self-publishing book company that David had used. So Angela Dunning gets up to deliver her defense, which is also pretty straightforward.
在那之后，他的口头辩论基本上可以总结为：你应该驳回这个案子。还有，能不能请你让PETA支付我的律师费？杜伊说完后，安吉拉·邓宁站了起来。她是共同被告的律师。PETA也起诉了大卫使用的一家自助出版图书公司。所以安吉拉·邓宁站起来进行辩护，也非常直接。
Naruto can't benefit financially from his work. He's a monkey.
纳鲁托无法从他的作品中获得经济利益。他是一只猴子。
David Slater wasn't in court in San Francisco that day. He didn't want to spend the money to travel all the way to California from Wales. But he watched the whole hearing online.
大卫·斯莱特那天没有在旧金山的法庭。他不想花钱从威尔士一直飞到加州。但他在线观看了整个听证会。
When I watched it-- and you see three judges there. And then one attorney comes up, and then my attorney comes up, Andrew and then Angela, and they started talking about monkeys. It made it real all of a sudden.
当我观看时——你看到那里有三位法官。然后一位律师上来，然后是我的律师，安德鲁，还有安吉拉，他们开始谈论猴子。那一刻，这变得真实起来。
That, yes, he was being sued by a monkey. Naruto didn't make it to the hearing either. He stayed in the rainforest in Indonesia. And to my knowledge, nobody asked him what he thought of all this. After two years, the humans managed to figure things out on their own. They told the appellate court they didn't want it to rule in the case after all.
那就是，是的，他正被一只猴子起诉。纳鲁托也没有出席听证会。他待在印度尼西亚的雨林里。据我所知，没有人问过他对这一切有什么看法。两年后，人类设法自己解决了问题。他们告诉上诉法院，毕竟他们不想让案件判决。
And in September, David and PETA announced they'd reached a settlement. The details of the settlement are confidential. So I can't tell you much about it. But here's what I do know. David Slater still has the monkey selfie copyright registered in his name in two countries. And he agreed to donate 25% of the proceeds of the photos to protect the crested macaques.
9月，大卫和PETA宣布达成和解。和解协议的细节是保密的。所以我不能多说。但我知道的是：大卫·斯莱特仍然拥有在两个国家以他的名字注册的猴子自拍版权。他同意将照片收益的25%捐赠给保护黑冠猕猴。
About Wikipedia, they've still got the monkey selfie up there for anyone to download. They still claim it's in the public domain. David will have to sue them to get it taken down, which he says he plans to do.
关于维基百科，他们仍然保留着那张猴子自拍供任何人下载。他们仍然声称它属于公有领域。大卫将不得不通过起诉他们来将其撤下，他说他计划这么做。
There's just one other thing that should be mentioned about Naruto. There were a bunch of monkeys around when the selfies were being taken that day. And PETA consulted with the primatologist who works with those crested black macaques. She's the one who identified Naruto as the monkey in the famous selfie. But David says that's not right.
关于纳鲁托还有一点应该提到。那天自拍时周围有一群猴子。PETA咨询了一位与那些黑冠猕猴一起工作的灵长类动物学家。正是她确定了纳鲁托就是那张著名自拍中的猴子。但大卫说那是不对的。
Naruto is a male. I distinctly remember it being a female. I distinctly remember that pink rump which the female macaques have.
纳鲁托是雄性。我清楚地记得那是只雌性。我清楚地记得雌性猕猴特有的那种粉红色臀部。
Basically what you're saying is is that Naruto is making a fraudulent claim himself.
你基本上是在说纳鲁托自己在进行欺诈性索赔。
Yes. It's the wrong monkey in court.
是的。法庭上的猴子弄错了。
He's taking credit for an artistic work that was actually made by a female monkey.
他正在为一个实际上由一只雌性猴子创作的艺术作品揽功。
Yeah. And I think the feminists amongst us should start to protest.
是的。我认为我们中间的女权主义者应该开始抗议了。
I'm sure she's not the first lady monkey to have this kind of experience.
我相信她不是第一个经历过这种事的雌性猴子。
It's in the nature of both humans and monkeys to horse around in front of cameras. But it's a uniquely human characteristic to spend hundreds of thousands of dollars, years of our lives, to go to court over it.
在相机前“猴里猴气”是人和猴子的天性。但花费数十万美元，浪费几年生命，为此闹上法庭，却是人类独有的特征。
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our show. Coming up-- our first act was about a monkey horsing around. Next up, we have a horse monkeying around. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio. When our program continues.
达娜·奇维斯是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来——我们的第一幕是关于一只猴子耍宝。接下来，我们有一匹马在“猴里猴气”。那就在一分钟后。来自芝加哥公共广播电台。节目继续。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme in today's show, So a Monkey and a Horse Walk Into a Bar. Today we have stories of people trying to completely erase the line between animal and human.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事，今天的节目是《猴子和马走进酒吧》。今天我们有关于人们试图彻底抹去动物和人类之间界限的故事。
We've arrived at act two of our program. Act two, If Wishes Were Horses. So there was a thing that we were interested in for this week's show that's at the heart of this new short piece of fiction by Amy Bonnaffons. Here it is. This is an excerpt from a longer story read by two actors, Grace Gummer and Geraldine Hughes. Quick warning that this story acknowledges the existence of sex.
我们到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《如果愿望是马》。对于本周的节目，我们感兴趣的一件事是艾米·博纳丰这篇新的短篇小说中的核心内容。就是这样。这是由两位演员格蕾丝·古默和杰拉尔丁·休斯朗读的较长故事的节选。快速提醒一下，这个故事承认性的存在。
Every morning we meet in the kitchen and unsheathe our needles. My roommate Serena delicately peels down her underwear. I count to three, hold her hip to steady her trembling frame, then jab, thrusting the handle until the fluid disappears.
每天早上我们在厨房见面，拔出针头。我的室友塞雷娜细心地脱下内衣。我数到三，按住她的臀部以稳住她颤抖的身躯，然后扎进去，推进推杆直到药液消失。
Then it's my turn. We're in this together, at least for now. The two needles look identical, although their contents are different. We have different goals. Serena wants to become a mother. I want to become a horse.
然后轮到我了。我们在一起，至少目前是这样。两根针看起来一模一样，但内容却不同。我们的目标不同。塞雷娜想成为母亲。我想成为一匹马。
What does it mean to be a horse? First, it means not being a person-- no credit cards, no fad diets, no existential questions, no more boring meetings or family dinners, no political allegiances or disappointments, no responsibility to anyone but yourself. How do I become one? It's quite simple. State your desire in writing, and we'll take it from there.
成为一匹马意味着什么？首先，这意味着不再是人——没有信用卡，没有减肥时尚，没有存在主义问题，不再有无聊的会议或家庭晚餐，没有政治倾向或失望，除了对自己以外对任何人都没有责任。我该怎么变成马？很简单。以书面形式陈述你的愿望，剩下的我们来处理。
Is it expensive? No. Why not? Because there's not yet sufficient demand for the procedure. All the more reason for you to try before it becomes pricey and exclusive. Right now, it costs less than a Pilates vacation in Tulum.
贵吗？不。为什么不？因为目前对这项手术的需求还不够大。这就是为什么要在它变得昂贵且稀有之前尝试的原因。现在，它的费用比在图卢姆的普拉提度假还要便宜。
I wanted something human existence couldn't offer. As I neared my 40th birthday, I felt increasingly constricted by daily postures-- sitting in a chair at my desk, cocking my head with feigned interest at a party, stirring spaghetti sauce over the stove. I started taking expensive vacations to engage in extreme physical challenges-- mountain climbing, skydiving, snowboarding.
我想要一些人类生活无法提供的东西。随着我接近40岁生日，我感到被日常姿势所束缚——坐在办公桌前的椅子上，在聚会上装作感兴趣地歪着头，在炉子上搅拌意大利面酱。我开始进行昂贵的度假，以参与极端的身体挑战——登山、跳伞、滑雪。
These pursuits all induced a feeling of mastery and freedom, but only after learning a complex set of rules regarding harnesses, buckles, and straps. I wanted to do away with constraints entirely. Then I learned about becoming a horse.
这些追求都带来了掌握感和自由感，但在学习了一套关于安全带、带扣和绑带的复杂规则之后。我想彻底消除这些限制。然后我得知了成为马的事。
How does the process work? The process now known as equinification was discovered by Janus Belacek, a Hungarian doctor, transforming human DNA into horse DNA. The process requires only a simple series of shots.
这个过程是如何运作的？这个现在被称为“马化”的过程是由匈牙利医生雅努斯·贝拉切克发现的，将人类DNA转化为马DNA。这个过程只需要一系列简单的注射。
Why does it only work on women? We're not sure, but we think it's because they want it to. Where do these horse women live? Atalanta Ranch, which occupies an entire island off the coast of Florida, and has been built expressly for this purpose.
为什么它只对女性有效？我们不确定，但我们认为是因为她们想这样做。这些马女住在哪里？亚特兰大牧场，它占据了佛罗里达海岸外的一整个岛屿，专门为此目的建造。
What do the horses on the ranch look like? They look like horses, tall, graceful animals designed for running and grazing, muscles rippling beneath a shiny coat of fur, hair flying in the wind. They look like they're doing nothing other than actively being themselves.
牧场上的马长什么样？它们看起来像马，高大、优雅、为奔跑和吃草而生，皮毛下肌肉起伏，毛发在风中飘扬。它们看起来除了积极地做自己之外什么都不做。
Of course, I went to visit. The ranch was just as they described. The horses looked healthy and vibrant. Their hooves pounded across the plains making a sound like rainfall. "Do you think this is some kind of modern version of the lesbian separatist utopia?" I mused that night to Kathy, one of the other women on the tour, over gin and tonics at the island's guesthouse. "Except not just for lesbians?"
当然，我去了参观。牧场正如他们描述的那样。马看起来健康而充满活力。它们的蹄子在大草原上敲击，发出像下雨般的声音。“你认为这是某种现代版的女性分离主义乌托邦吗？”那天晚上在岛上的招待所里，喝着金汤力，我对着旅行团里的另一位女士凯西沉思道。“只是不仅仅是针对女同性恋者？”
She laughed. "Old fantasies die hard." She gave me a meaningful look. "Can I ask something? What's your reason?" "Boredom," I said without hesitation. She nodded. "What about you?" I said. "What are you escaping?"
她笑了。“古老的幻想总是难以消逝。”她给了我一个意味深长的眼神。“我能问一件事吗？你的理由是什么？”“无聊，”我毫不犹豫地说。她点了点头。“你呢？”我说。“你在逃避什么？”
She replied with a long story about her body, which had endured nearly every tried and true form of female trauma-- abuse, rape, abortion, endometriosis, hysterectomy. "I guess," she said, "I want a different body with a clean slate." They kept refilling our drinks without our asking. And soon we were very drunk.
她回答了一个关于她身体的长故事，它经历过几乎所有女性创伤的各种形式——虐待、强奸、流产、子宫内膜异位症、子宫切除术。“我想，”她说，“我想要一个全新的身体。”他们不断地给我们续杯，都没问我们。很快我们就喝醉了。
Somehow, we found ourselves in my room stripping off our clothes. This sex was like a competition. Who could manage to escape her body using the other's body first? Later, embarrassed, we turned away from each other. Just then I sensed movement behind the window. I got up stark naked and pulled aside the curtain.
不知何故，我们发现自己在我的房间里脱掉了衣服。这种性行为就像一场竞争。谁能先利用对方的身体逃离自己的身体？后来，尴尬地，我们转过身去。就在这时，我感觉到窗户后面有动静。我一丝不挂地起身，拉开窗帘。
One of the horses was standing right outside, staring in with her dark liquid eyes. I felt the bed creak behind me then heard Kathy gasp. She saw it too. The horse gave a deep, slow nod. Then she turned and disappeared into the night.
其中一匹马就站在窗外，用她深邃如液体的眼睛盯着里面。我感到身后床吱吱作响，然后听到凯西倒吸一口凉气。她也看到了。那匹马深沉而缓慢地点了点头。然后她转身消失在夜色中。
When I become a horse, will I still have human consciousness? You will simultaneously be your human self and not be your human self when you become a horse. You will think the same thoughts, but in a horsey manner.
当我变成马时，我还会有人类的意识吗？当你变成马时，你将同时是人类的自己，又不是人类的自己。你会有同样的思想，但以马的方式。
Your personality will have the same attributes but horsily expressed. Your thoughts will take on a horsey cadence. Your feelings will pulse and throb with thick, horsey blood. We cannot guarantee that you will continue to inhabit your human identity in any recognizable way.
你的个性会有同样的属性，但以马的方式表达。你的思想将带上马的节奏。你的感觉将伴随着厚重的、马的血液跳动。我们不能保证你会以任何可辨认的方式继续保持你的人类身份。
Serena went to the doctor and found out that her second attempt at IVF had failed. "We don't say failed," the doctor said kindly. "We say unsuccessful." "It's almost as bad," said Serena. Serena and I became friends in a PhD program. I dropped out after our third year when I realized that the most pleasurable part of my life was my summer waitressing job.
塞雷娜去看了医生，发现她第二次试管婴儿尝试失败了。“我们不说失败，”医生亲切地说。“我们说不成功。”“这几乎一样糟糕，”塞雷娜说。我和塞雷娜是在博士项目中成为朋友的。我在第三年后退学了，因为我意识到我生命中最快乐的部分是我夏天的服务员工作。
But it got old. I tried a few other restaurant jobs then finally settled for freelance copyediting, for which my half degree apparently qualified me. Serena graduated with honors and won an award for her thesis on 18th century women's novels. But after graduation, despite her accolades, she couldn't find a job.
但那也老了。我试过几份其他的餐饮工作，最后勉强做了自由职业的文案，我的半个学位显然有资格做这个。塞雷娜以优异成绩毕业，并因关于18世纪女性小说论文获得了奖项。但毕业后，尽管有赞誉，她却找不到工作。
I encouraged her but privately ascribed her failure to her meekness with strangers. In the end, she got a job teaching English at an all-girls high school. To her surprise, the girls recognized her quiet power and obeyed her, surrounded her with a mute halo of reverence. She became one of the school's most beloved teachers. Yet no matter how deeply the work absorbed her, she always felt like a failure.
我鼓励她，但私下里把她的失败归咎于她对陌生人的温顺。最后，她在一家全女子高中找到了教英语的工作。令她惊讶的是，女孩们认可了她安静的力量并服从她，用一种沉默的崇敬光环围绕着她。她成了学校里最受欢迎的老师之一。然而，无论工作多么投入，她总觉得自己是个失败者。
Isn't this really a glorified form of suicide? We prefer to think of it in the opposite way, as a kind of birth. But your friends and relatives may not see it this way. You may have to prepare them for your transformation as you might for your death. Will I need to make out a will then? Yes. You may not bring anything with you to Atalanta Ranch beside your body.
这不真的是一种美化形式的自杀吗？我们倾向于以相反的方式思考，作为一种出生。但你的朋友和亲戚可能不会这样看。你可能必须像准备死亡一样为你的转型做准备。那我需要立遗嘱吗？是的。除了你的身体，你不能带任何东西去亚特兰大牧场。
It started happening right after my 40th birthday in June. I woke up in the middle of the night with a strange feeling in my feet-- not pain exactly, but pressure so intense it absorbed my whole attention. I cried out in surprise, and Serena rushed into my room.
它是在我6月份40岁生日后立即发生的。我半夜醒来，脚上有种奇怪的感觉——不是疼痛，但压力如此剧烈，占据了我所有的注意力。我惊讶地大叫，塞雷娜冲进我的房间。
And then we pulled back the covers to see that my feet had been replaced by perfect horse hooves, black and stone-like, cloven in the middle. As predicted by the pamphlets, I felt disgust then wonder. The pamphlet said--
然后我们掀开被子，发现我的脚已经被完美的马蹄取代了，黑色且像石头，中间裂开。正如宣传册所预测的那样，我感到了厌恶，然后是敬畏。宣传册上写着——
The transformation of your own body will be a spectacle arousing both revulsion and awe.
你身体的改变将是一场既令人反感又令人敬畏的奇观。
I got up and tried to walk around. Serena and I both giggled manically. My hooves were tender, and it hurt to walk on them, like when my feet used to ache at the end of a night on high heels. I felt lopsided and clumsy. These hooves weren't made to carry a bipedal organism.
我起身试图走动。我和塞雷娜都疯狂地咯咯大笑。我的马蹄很嫩，走起来很疼，就像我以前穿着高跟鞋工作一晚后脚疼一样。我感到倾斜且笨拙。这些马蹄不是为了承载双足生物而造的。
But hearing their clop, clop, clop around the floors of the apartment, I grew excited. We couldn't sleep the rest of the night. We stayed up rereading the informational pamphlets, speculating on how quickly the rest of me would start to turn. As if by magic, by some prearranged signal of the gods, Serena peed on a stick the next morning and discovered she was pregnant.
但听到它们在公寓地板上发出的“咔哒、咔哒”声，我变得兴奋起来。那晚剩下的时间我们都无法入睡。我们熬夜重读信息宣传册，推测我身体的其他部分会以多快速度开始改变。仿佛魔法一般，就像众神预先安排的信号，塞雷娜第二天早上在测试棒上小便，发现她怀孕了。
Are the horses tame or wild? The horses at the ranch are wild. We provide nothing but acreage for running and grazing. We do nothing to break them. There are no harnesses, no bridles, no whips. Among other purposes, the ranch exists in order to cultivate wildness.
马是驯服的还是野生的？牧场上的马是野生的。我们除了提供奔跑和吃草的土地外什么也不提供。我们不做任何驯服它们的事情。没有马具，没有笼头，没有鞭子。除了其他目的，牧场存在是为了培育野性。
What is wildness? And may wildness be cultivated? Isn't that a contradiction? That is what we're trying to find out. All we can say is either you personally resonate with this desire, or you don't. Either you like the idea of shaking off your restraints and are willing to give up everything you know in the attempt to do so, or you're like most people, comforted by language, by clothing, by laws.
什么是野性？野性可以被培育吗？那不是矛盾吗？这就是我们试图发现的。我们只能说，你要么个人对这种渴望产生共鸣，要么不。你要么喜欢摆脱束缚的想法，并且愿意在尝试中放弃你所知道的一切，要么你就像大多数人一样，被语言、服装、法律所安慰。
Walking around town with my hooves, I gained a new kind of attention. Women regarded me with disgust or envy, men with disgust or desire. My first night out at a bar with some friends, I was the object of many stares. But I sensed a particular heat coming from one man at a corner table.
带着马蹄在城里走动，我获得了新的关注。女人们厌恶或嫉妒地看着我，男人则厌恶或欲望。我第一次和朋友去酒吧的那晚，我成了许多注视的目标。但我感觉到一个坐在角落桌边的男人身上发出一种特殊的热度。
He wore the distinct, recognizable look of a graduate student-- floppy hair, and a lanky frame, and a too-large cotton hoodie. Every time I looked over at him, he turned away, red-faced. Eventually, when he approached the bar to get another drink, I addressed him.
他穿着典型的、可辨认的研究生模样——松软的头发，瘦长的身躯，一件过大的棉质连帽衫。每次我看他时，他都脸红着转过头去。最后，当他走到吧台去喝另一杯饮料时，我叫住了他。
"Hey," I said. He blushed again, flicked his eyes down to my hooves, then back up, then blushed deeper. "Hey," he said. "Am I the first you've seen?" "Yeah," he said. "Sorry, I guess I was staring." "It's OK." "Is that-- is that the only part of you that's--?" "So far, yes."
“嘿，”我说。他又脸红了，眼睛向下瞥了瞥我的马蹄，然后又抬起来，然后脸变得更红了。“嘿，”他说。“我是你见过的第一个吗？”“是的，”他说。“对不起，我想我盯着看了。”“没关系。”“那是——那是你身上唯一的部分吗——？”“到目前为止，是的。”
He nodded, swallowed. I grabbed a pen from my purse, scribbled my number on a napkin. I wasn't particularly attracted to him, but I had been horny since my hooves had appeared. "My friends and I are about to head to another bar. But if you want to meet up later, text me. I'll be free by midnight."
他点了点头，咽了咽口水。我从钱包里抓出一支笔，在餐巾纸上写下我的号码。我对他并没有特别的吸引力，但自从我的马蹄出现后，我就一直处于发情状态。“我和朋友们准备去另一家酒吧。但如果你以后想见面，发短信给我。我午夜前有空。”
Later that night, in his spartan studio apartment, he stared at me as if he'd never seen a woman before. I felt his gaze lingering on the spot where the slope of my ankle gave way to the ashen density of the hoof. But as he reached out to touch me, a violent, molten feeling welled up within me. I recognized it as rage.
那天晚上晚些时候，在他简朴的单间公寓里，他盯着我，好像他从来没见过女人一样。我感觉到他的目光停留在我脚踝的斜度让位于马蹄灰暗密度的地方。但当他伸手去摸我时，一股猛烈的、熔岩般的感觉在我体内涌起。我认出那是愤怒。
But it was too late. It had already happened. I had kicked him. He jerked backward, his hands to his face. Blood seeped out between his fingers. He said something or tried to, but all I heard was, [GROANING]. The old me would have gone and fetched him a towel, called him a taxi, accompanied him to the hospital.
但已经太晚了。它已经发生了。我踢了他。他猛地后退，双手捂住脸。血从他指缝间渗出来。他说了什么或者试图说，但我听到的只是呻吟声。以前的我本会去给他拿条毛巾，给他叫辆出租车，陪他去医院。
But the sight of his bloody face only increased my rage, tinged it with contempt for his weakness. I fought the urge to kick him again, harder. It was all I could do to get out of the house. I hurried down the stairs of his walk-up, pushed open the door, and ran through the streets of Somerville, awkward on my hooved limbs but propelled by the heat his near touch had unleashed.
但看到他血淋淋的脸只增加了我的愤怒，带上对他软弱的蔑视。我竭力忍住再给他重重一脚的冲动。我能做的只是离开那房子。我冲下他的公寓楼梯，推开门，在萨默维尔的街道上奔跑，在马蹄上笨拙但被他触碰引发的热度所驱使。
I ran past university gates, over the bridge, through Boston at full sprint. At some point, I realized my awkward gait had been replaced by something graceful and rhythmic and, well, horse-like. I had stopped noticing the strangeness of my hooves. I was using them as they were meant to be used. I was cantering.
我跑过大学大门，跑过桥，全速冲过波士顿。在某个时刻，我意识到我笨拙的步态已经被某种优雅、有节奏的、嗯，像马一样的步伐取代了。我已经不再注意到我马蹄的奇怪之处了。我正以它们本该被使用的方式使用它们。我在慢跑。
By the time I approached my own neighborhood, I'd slowed to a trot, but I felt elated. My very nature was changing. I was becoming wild. The man's touch had been a bridle, and I'd kicked it away.
当我接近自己社区时，我已经放慢了脚步，但我感到兴高采烈。我的本性在改变。我正在变得野性。男人的触摸曾是一个缰绳，而我把它踢开了。
What symptoms might I experience during my transformation? The same symptoms you would experience during any transformation-- mood swings, growing pains, strained relationships, the occasional blinding toothache. To find a centaurite support group near you, consult our website.
我在转型期间可能会经历什么症状？你在任何转型期间会经历同样的症状——情绪波动、生长痛、紧张的人际关系、偶尔的牙疼。要查找附近的半人马支持小组，请访问我们的网站。
Over the next few months, the change slowly inched upwards. My human ankles became horse ankles. I grew coarse, caramel-colored hair on my legs. My femurs stretched and thickened. Occasionally, I felt sharp pains in my bones, growing pains. But other than that, the physical transition felt invigorating.
在接下来的几个月里，变化慢慢向上延伸。我人类的脚踝变成了马的脚踝。我的腿上长出了粗糙的、焦糖色的毛发。我的股骨伸展并变厚。偶尔，我会感到骨头有阵痛，生长痛。但除此之外，身体的转变感觉令人振奋。
My rage, however, only grew. I was energized by aimless, volcanic fury 100% of the time. Perhaps I wasn't changing my nature but recognizing something that had always been there. My boredom had never really been boredom but rather a deep, deep anger.
然而，我的愤怒只增不减。我一直被毫无目的、火山般的愤怒所激励。也许我并没有改变本性，而是认出了一些一直存在的东西。我的无聊从来都不是真正的无聊，而是一种深刻的、深深的愤怒。
Where had this come from? Did everyone have it? My anger was obvious now to everyone I met. I responded to routine rudenesses, catcalling, crowding on the subway by snarling, flashing my eyes, baring my teeth. People's eyes grew wide. They stepped back. They treated me like the dangerous animal I was. I loved it.
这来自哪里？每个人都有吗？我的愤怒现在对我遇到的每个人都很明显。我对日常的粗鲁、猫叫、地铁上的拥挤做出反应，通过咆哮、闪烁眼睛、露出牙齿。人们眼睛睁大了。他们退缩了。他们像对待危险动物一样对待我。我喜欢这样。
Serena, too, was changing. The pregnancy had rooted in her body, and she blossomed. The first sonogram showed not one but two fetuses in her belly. Every moment she wasn't teaching, she was at the computer researching the development of the strange creatures inside of her.
塞雷娜也在改变。怀孕已经在她身体里扎根，她绽放了。第一次超声波显示她的肚子里不是一个，而是两个胎儿。她不教书的每一刻，她都在电脑前研究她腹中那些奇怪生物的发展。
I, on the other hand, found myself unable to sit still. I'd sit down, get through one paragraph, then feel it kick through me, the wildness, the aimless rage. Then one evening, I got so frustrated with my work that I stood up and kicked a hole right through the kitchen cabinet.
另一方面，我发现自己无法安静坐下来。我会坐下，读完一段，然后感到它在我体内奔涌，那野性，那毫无目的的愤怒。然后一天晚上，我对自己的工作感到非常沮丧，以至于我站起来，一脚踢穿了橱柜。
Serena appeared in the doorway, pale, one hand on the swell of her belly. We stared at each other, gripped by the same mute question. How much longer could we go on like this sharing the same space? That night, lying in bed, I heard the unmistakable sound of muffled weeping.
塞雷娜出现在门口，脸色苍白，一只手按在隆起的腹部。我们盯着对方，被同一个沉默的问题所困扰。我们还能这样共享空间多久？那天晚上，躺在床上，我听到了无法辨认的压抑哭泣声。
I got up, knocked lightly on Serena's door. I walked in, sat on the edge of the bed, lightly stroked her hair. "What's the matter?" I said. "Nothing," she choked out. But before I could respond, she corrected herself. "I'm terrified. This is the biggest thing I've ever done, and I'm doing it totally alone."
我起身，轻轻敲了敲塞雷娜的门。我走进去，坐在床边，轻轻抚摸她的头发。“怎么了？”我说。“没什么，”她哽咽道。但在我能回应之前，她纠正了自己。“我很害怕。这是我做过的最大的事，而我完全是一个人在做。”
"You have your family," I said. "You have your friends." "Yeah, except for you." "You can come visit me," I said. "Bring your kids to the ranch." "Tell them what?"
“你有你的家人，”我说。“你有你的朋友。”“是的，除了你。”“你可以来找我，”我说。“带你的孩子去牧场。”“告诉他们什么？”
"This is your aunt Cassie. She was restless and turned herself into an animal." "That's supposed to be an example of some sort? Things get hard, and you just leave? Just peace out of human life entirely?"
“这是你的卡西阿姨。她很不安，把自己变成了一只动物。”“那应该是一个例子吗？事情变难了，你就这样离开了？就这样完全退出人类生活？”
In the greenish light coming through the window, Serena seemed distinct and alien, like someone I had never seen, really seen, before. The protrusion of her belly was impossible to ignore. There were two whole people in there. For the first time, the terrifying marvel of this fact hit me full force. Perhaps her transformation was even stranger, even wilder than mine.
在透过窗户射进来的绿色光芒中，塞雷娜显得疏离且外星，像一个我从未真正看过的人。她腹部的突出是不可能忽视的。里面有两个完整的人。这是第一次，这一事实的恐怖奇迹完全击中了我。也许她的转变比我的更奇怪，更野性。
Is the change reversible? No change is ever reversible. What happens if the process doesn't work on me? You'll get your money back. And we may ask you to participate in an ongoing scientific study of long-term centaurite health outcomes, for compensation. But you may decline.
这种改变是可逆的吗？没有改变是可逆的。如果这个过程对我不起作用会怎样？你会得到退款。我们可能会要求你参与一项关于长期半人马健康的科学研究，作为报酬。但你可以拒绝。
That's it? It's not possible for us to do more. Our hope is that the centaurites living among us will be viewed not as freaks or as failures, but as courageous-- female animals who gathered up all the uncertainties of their existence into one single, massive risk.
就这样吗？我们不可能做更多了。我们的希望是，生活在我们中间的半人马将被视为勇敢——聚集了她们存在的所有不确定性，承担了一次单一的、巨大的风险的女性动物，而不是被视为怪胎或失败者。
I went for a checkup with the Atalanta doctor. The visit was routine, had been scheduled for months. But I was nervous. My progress since the last visit seemed to have stalled. She examined me all over and said "hmm" a lot. I grew increasingly worried.
我和亚特兰大的医生进行了例行检查。访问是例行的，已经安排了几个月了。但我很紧张。我上次访问后的进展似乎陷入停滞。她仔细检查了我全身，说了好多次“嗯”。我越来越担心。
When I got home from the doctors, I saw that yet another delivery of baby stuff-- hand-me-downs from friends, large Amazon boxes full of equipment-- had arrived at the apartment and completely taken over the living room. To reach the couch, I had to pick my way over and between the boxes, stepping as delicately as possible with my horse legs, legs that were not made to do anything delicately.
当我从医生那里回到家时，我看到又有另一批婴儿用品——朋友给的旧货，装满设备的亚马逊大箱子——到达了公寓，完全占领了客厅。为了到达沙发，我不得不小心翼翼地绕过箱子，用我的马腿尽可能细致地踏过，那些腿根本不是为了细致做事而造的。
Even when I got there, I couldn't sit down. It was piled high with baby clothes. I lost it. I whirled around and began kicking with an aimless violence that startled me with its force. I had not intended this. I was beyond intention. Like if I stopped kicking and hurling things, I would cease to exist.
即使我到了那里，我也无法坐下。上面堆满了婴儿衣服。我崩溃了。我转过身，开始以一种毫无目的的暴力踢东西，其力量让我感到惊讶。我没打算这样。我已经失去了控制。就像如果我停止踢东西和扔东西，我就会停止存在。
By the time I managed to stop, I had wrecked not only most of the new baby equipment but also the large flat screen television and the coffee table. I looked around at the torn baby blankets strewn with broken glass, the mutilated breast pump, the mangled stroller. Just then, a key turned in the lock, and Serena stood in the doorway.
当我设法停下来时，我不仅破坏了大部分新的婴儿设备，还破坏了那台大平板电视和咖啡桌。我看着撕碎的、散落着玻璃碎片的婴儿毯，被摧毁的吸奶器，破损的婴儿车。就在这时，锁里钥匙响了，塞雷娜站在门口。
She looked from me to the mess, from the mess back to me. Her face hardened. I could offer no defense or consolation. I had only one option. "I'm going to leave now," I said. "I'll find someplace else to stay." She nodded with no expression.
她看着我，看着那一团糟，又从那一团糟看着我。她的脸僵硬了。我无法提供任何辩护或安慰。我只有一个选择。“我现在要走了，”我说。“我会找别的地方住。”她没有任何表情地点了点头。
I walked aimlessly, vaguely in the direction of the downtown hotels. My muscles grew leaden with shame. I felt like I was walking underwater. What pained me was not the notion that my wildness, my horseyness, had finally overtaken me.
我毫无目的地走着，大致朝市中心酒店的方向。我的肌肉因羞耻而沉重。我觉得自己像在水下行走。让我痛苦的不是我的野性、我的马性终于战胜了我的想法。
It was the suspicion that my violence had been entirely human. That night, under a scratchy hotel blanket, I contemplated my situation. For the first time in nearly a year, I cried-- sobbing into the lumpy pillow, mourning the grotesque monster that I was, howling at my failure, my loneliness, my inadequacy as woman and as animal. Eventually, from sheer exhaustion, I slept.
而是我怀疑我的暴力完全是人类的。那天晚上，在粗糙的酒店毯子下，我思考着我的处境。这是近一年来我第一次哭泣——对着凸凹不平的枕头啜泣，哀悼我这个怪异的怪物，哀嚎我的失败、我的孤独、我作为女人和动物的不称职。最后，由于精疲力竭，我睡着了。
When I woke in the morning, I saw that during my few hours of sleep the fur had finally reached upwards. My breasts were gone, replaced by a fine equine torso. I raised my hands to touch it, then realized that they had been replaced by another set of hooves. I felt practically ambushed by relief.
早上醒来时，我看到在睡觉的几个小时里，皮毛终于向上延伸了。我的乳房不见了，被一个精细的马匹躯干所取代。我抬起手去摸它，然后意识到它们已经被另一套马蹄所取代。我几乎被解脱感所淹没。
I went downstairs to the concierge, asked her to use her human fingers to make a phone call. Red-faced and excited, she rang Atalanta. They would send someone that afternoon, they said, to pick me up.
我下楼去礼宾部，请她用她人类的手指打了个电话。满脸通红且兴奋，她拨打了亚特兰大。他们说那天下午会派人来接我。
Can my loved ones visit me at the ranch? Yes. Will they recognize me? Most of them claim to, but it's impossible to determine how much this recognition depends upon wishful thinking. Can they ride me? We don't recommend it. So far, every attempt has ended in tragedy.
我爱的人可以在牧场看我吗？可以。他们会认出我吗？他们大多数人都声称会，但无法确定这种认出在多大程度上取决于一厢情愿。他们可以骑我吗？我们不建议这样做。到目前为止，每一次尝试都以悲剧告终。
I have four horse legs, and a horse torso, and a horse head. Outwardly, at least, I am all animal. I believe I still have a human brain mostly. But every day, its language grows rougher around the edges. For minutes at a time when I'm running or eating in the pasture, I have no thoughts.
我有四条马腿，一个马躯干和一个马头。至少在外表上，我全是动物。我相信我仍然拥有基本的人类大脑。但每一天，它的语言在边缘变得越来越粗糙。当我奔跑或在牧场吃草时，我有几分钟的时间没有思想。
My brain is not empty exactly. It's as though a hot wind blows certain textures through my mind. My rage has diminished, but I am neither contained nor calm. I feel many emotions now, but they don't quite fit the words I know. I would describe them mostly as variations of active receptivity, of alert acceptance.
我的大脑并不完全是空的。就像一阵热风把某些纹理吹进我的脑海里。我的愤怒减少了，但我既不克制也不冷静。我现在感觉到了许多情绪，但它们并不完全适合我知道的词汇。我主要把它们描述为主动接受、警觉接受的变体。
Somewhere soon, Serena will be teaching her children the words for things. This is a table. This is a chair. This is a horse. Meanwhile, my language is slowly departing, the words replaced by syllable and breath-- yes, mm, yes, huh, no, mm, [WHINNYING].
不久之后，塞雷娜会教她的孩子事物的名称。这是桌子。这是椅子。这是马。与此同时，我的语言在慢慢离我而去，词汇被音节和呼吸所取代——是的，嗯，是的，呵，不，嗯，[马嘶鸣]。
Maybe she'll come visit me one day. Perhaps in my absence her hard judgments of me will soften, turn into questions. They will lead her to me across the long grass. And I'll look at her and nod. She won't try to ride me, but I'll let her approach, put a hand on my forehead. We'll both feel a sudden snare of recognition-- wildness face-to-face with itself.
也许有一天她会来看我。也许在我缺席时，她对我严厉的评判会软化，变成疑问。它们会引领她穿过长草来到我身边。我会看着她点点头。她不会试图骑我，但我会让她靠近，把手放在我的额头上。我们都会感受到一阵突然的认同感——野性面对面地看着自己。
Grace Gummer and Geraldine Hughes reading a short story by Amy Bonnaffons. It's a part of her collection of short stories called The Wrong Heaven, which is available for preorder at Amazon and elsewhere.
格蕾丝·古默和杰拉尔丁·休斯朗读艾米·博纳丰的短篇小说。这是她短篇小说集《错误的伊甸园》的一部分，该书可在亚马逊和其他地方预订。
We're program was produced today by Robyn Semien. Our staff includes Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Kimberly Henderson, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, B.A. Parker, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作。我们的员工包括艾尔娜·贝克、伊莉斯·伯格森、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、金伯利·亨德森、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、塞思·林德、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、B.A.帕克、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Special thanks today to Leo Mankiewicz. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he was explaining to me the other day why he had a horse in a hot tub.
我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。今天特别感谢里奥·曼凯维奇。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，前几天他还在向我解释为什么他在热水浴缸里养了一匹马。
This is one of the secrets, actually, of being able to get good photography is making the animal relaxed.
这实际上是能拍出好照片的秘诀之一，就是让动物放松。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。